so if you decided to uh take
on your own challenge of uh listening
and acting out on the first and second
uh
film that I'm suggesting that you can
become your own uh Uchi dasi program so
this this is designed as I would as if
you were living with me and every day we
would get up at 700 in the morning H go
into the Dojo or outside depending on
the weather and we would do the weapons
first in the morning and the targets at
night if you managed to buy some mats uh
that you can do your C on fantastic or
if you have been able to find the time
to practice it uh before class or even
after class is okay personally I think
before class cuz that's when you have to
look out after your body the most and uh
and you're getting on well with doing
those
ukis forward
ukas
um is what you're mainly doing but back
blue chemis are very important but they
do take time as I've said before uh
you've got to work out where your head's
going to go uh and you don't want
dislocate anything or or hurt yourself
so let's hope that's going okay then we
moved on to the weapons and you're
trying to get three of each of the
Kerber out of the
five uh then P do five see how you're
getting on how many you're getting to
feel the same perhaps none of them are
feel the same so what you do is you
don't do repeat it and do another five
immediately when you've got the five um
I wouldn't
say uh five if I if I meant 10 so you
know you don't do five and quickly think
well none of them felt the same I'll
just do them again uh you do need to
bring down like a shutter where you use
a sort of a meditative state where you
close your
eyes breathe in through the nose out
through the mouth you do need to make a
a a space between what you've just
done the information comes back to you
in your mind
you desire for the information if you're
not happy with it you need to make that
break because the next five must be a
fresh five they mustn't just be a
repetition of the five you've done
hoping that that they'll be better they
won't you have to have a
clear um I remember s sense used to
say you can never repeat the one you've
just
had one is one
so this is a great way to think about
things I'm then contradicting it by
saying if you can get three first ker
berries or any
Kerber out of the five that you're going
to do you can get three that felt
exactly identical as if you're like a
little robotic machine going tick tick
tick tick tick tick and if every part of
it felt and and exactly the
same then you're doing really well it
may take as I've said before months
years if it happens in days it means
that perhaps you've been doing iido many
years
already so this program that I'm going
through is an IDI program and it's
designed for anybody Q grades D grades
teachers it doesn't matter if you want
to get fit but you want want to improve
on your iido then you need a fitness and
a a training regime if you just do any
anything um then you're not really
building a a wall of of a solid solid
mass and a Way Forward of systematically
getting
better so we've done new
chis we then the second film moved on to
the Canon Joe
you
so what I think I forgot to say in the
suburb one is you do five then pause
clear your mind then perhaps 30 seconds
to 1 minute you need to pause even just
walk up and down the room or put the K
down the Joe
down and just break from that uh first
group if you're if you're lacky enough
to give 30 minutes A Night to it well
night morning doesn't matter when you do
it uh when you can spare the time if you
can give 30 minutes to it make sure that
even if you do 20 30 sets of fives you
do have a break between each set of five
do not do repetitions over and over
again you just get frustrated and it
won't work this is is all about
commitment to disciplining yourself
disciplining yourself as a martial
artist not as a human being we're
getting fit as a human being because we
need to get fit because our body is made
up of structure that needs to be worked
and um aerobic workouts are great um at
the same time is better breathing better
body
functions so we're doing this in the
cies especially um but for now with the
subur you're trying to get
accuracy so this is a third film and now
I'm going to be talking about
um going moving on so with the Ken you
do
hapoy now
hapoy um break it down again do two cuts
so do two cuts forwards turn back
forwards turn back forwards turn back
forwards you're trying to turn the same
keep the same structure of five so
you're going to cut forwards backwards
forwards backwards and do this repeating
it up to the count of
five are have you got the you know so
one two
one two one two one two one
two out of the five you're looking for
three of
those cuts with the Turning movement so
you're doing two cuts
for of repetitions of five and and and
you're aiming still for the
three uh three out of those two cuts to
feel the same smoothness weight balance
everything feet turning you know and
everything the whole mechanism must be
right it's no good saying well the cat
felt good but I felt my feet were a
little bit sticky as I turned the whole
thing must be in
unism So you you're looking for three of
those double
movements out of the
five once you've got that then go on to
Four Points again you're going for five
of the four
movements and you're trying to get to
the same three of feing the
same now because of
where the way our minds think if you
don't get it with the first two
movements you might think I'll do four
because perhaps that'll feel better than
the two or or I do I do um six because
that'll feel better than and then oh no
I'll do the
eight well you can do you can do 16 if
you want in the past I've done 16 you
just cut what call the the angles
Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter once you've gone on to the but
by rushing it just hoping that you're
going to feel smoothness and
continuity is a f is a falsehood it's a
false it's a false way of looking at it
I've seen so many students I've helped
over the years who try to think that the
next step will be the magic one to give
them the answer it doesn't work it's
better
to be haunted by why can't I get this
and look to improve the two cuts either
way than it is to go on to the four cuts
hoping that the two cuts will improve
and it doesn't matter what I say I know
already that you'll do this because it's
human nature to think that if I do more
I might get
it um and I'm smiling to myself because
I I know this because I've done it
myself and that's why I can tell you
clearly that um it's hard to be
disciplined enough to to to do
this so please try this with the Ken
haoi um only cuts it their first subur
Cuts once you've mastered the whole
eight
directions in
haoi and you can get in each Direction
three feeling the
same then you've got multiples of three
haven't you cuz because on the first one
forward one back you get three and then
the you're going to multiply that into
four uh directional cuts and once you
get the first three feeling
smooth if they don't feel smooth don't
go onto the fourth four movements even
if you've already started the four
movements it means they're not deep in
your body the first
two it's hard for me to say this because
I know you'll want to think well I've
done the three I've got on the first two
strikes backwards and forwards I want to
I've started the four I'm going to keep
trying on the four and make the
four uh
movements somehow feel that I can have
the five times I'm going to attempt
it I'm going to try and get to the three
feeling smoother on the new
two that I've added to it I hope you're
understanding what I'm saying and it's
not
confusing so first two movements forward
and back second two movements you go
uh different so first two
movements is forward turn back next one
is opposite so it's like a
across and then you have it again and
have it again and then you come back to
square
one
again uh a small breather a small Gap So
you you're going to attempt this uh five
times and even if you're on the six uh
movement
angles pause after you've done it five
repetitions of those six
angles have a breather you might have to
have a longer breathers while doing this
you might need to take more than 30
seconds or a minute you might have to
take even a few minutes breather because
it will be quite demanding from
you uh and there's your challenge with
the Ken you're going to do the
haoi and try to get three out of the
five repetitions
if there's any uh help you need or none
of this is quite uh you know
understanding uh to your understanding
please uh mail me or get in touch with
me somehow on Facebook or
wherever by email uh for more
explanations and I'll
gladly uh give you my time and see what
we can do to help you improve your iido
thank you